bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir l'un des meilleurs spécialistes de
l'histoire d'Israël et de la Palestine
bonsoir Vincent Lemire et merci beaucoup
d'être notre grand témoin ce soir votre
BD sur l'histoire de Jérusalem cartonne
en librairie c'est devenu même un un
phénomène tout comme votre podcast qui
marche très bien sur France interre
anatomie d'un conflit on va revenir avec
vous sur la fin de la trêve is et le
Hamas qui se rejette la responsabilité
de la reprise des combats dans la bande
de Gaza dans la 2uxème partie notre
grand débat ce soir et si on en
finissait avec les discriminations à
l'embauche et au logement c'est une
proposition de loi attendue qui sera
débattue lundi dans l'hémicycle porté
par un député Renaissance Marc ferci
elle a toutes les chances d'être adopté
grâce aux voix de la gauche la nouveauté
le testing de masse est-ce la solution
nous en débattons dans un instant sur ce
plateau avec mes invités enfin ns
affranchi ce soir la chronique écolo
spécial COP 28 de Léa Falco le mot de la
semaine de notre sémiologue Mariette tar
grand et puis Bourbon Express ça a
chauffé hier soir en commission des lois
vous le verrez avec Marco Pomier voilà
pour le menu on y va Vincent Lemir ça
vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti en France Mohamed 4 fois moins de
chance d'être recruté que Michel et le
climat dans le pays n'arrange rien le
rapport sur les discriminations à
l'embauche de l'Observatoire des
inégalités est accablant preuve s'il en
fallait encore une que la méritocratie
républicaine a du plomb dans l'aile
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait bonsoir Marc
ferci bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
député renaissance des Français qui
vivent en Suisse c'est vous l'auteur de
cette proposition de loi vous la
défendraz dès ce lundi dans l'hémicycle
bonsoir Moussa Camara ravi de vous
retrouver sur sur ce plateau vous êtes
le fondateur de l'association Les
déterminés qui aide les jeunes des
quartiers à créer leur propre entreprise
vous étiez venu ici nous parler de
déterminer comment on s'en sort au
presse de la cité bonsoir Dominique
sopoons ravi de vous retrouver également
vous êtes président d' SOS Racisme qui
pratique régulièrement des campagnes de
testing avec quelle efficacité on on y
reviendra bien sûr enfin bonsoir
Stéphanie leer merci d'être là vous êtes
DRH dans un gros cabinet de de
recrutement présidente de l'association
à compét égal vous nous direz ce que
vous faites sur le terrain forcément les
entreprises sont les premières pointées
Vincent Lemir vous intervenez quand vous
le souhaitez on commence par planter le
décor avec l'ami Stéphane blackovski
dans son chrono tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir
retourne je vous invite à faire la même
chose toutes et tous alors le tableau
des discriminations dans notre pays vous
savez qu'on a de la chance d'être en
France car c'est un pays qui est très
investi dans la lutte contre les les
discriminations la preuve regardez la
loi française recense et donc interdit
25 critères de discrimination donc en
premier le sexe l'origine vous voyez
c'est tellement vaste que chacun peut
s'y reconnaître et chacun donc peut être
visé par une discrimination
malheureusement malgré cet arsenal
juridique il y a bon nombre de Français
qui continuent de se sentir discriminés
et notamment dans le monde du travail
alors il y a des tonnes d'études sur le
sujet elles sont très souvent relayés
dans la presse donc vous voyez si vous
êtes Seigneur une chance enfin un sur tr
s discriminé mais si vous êtes jeune
c'est pareil un jeune sur trois lui
aussi a le sentiment d'avoir déjà été
discriminé au travail c'est encore pire
comme situation pour les femmes puisque
là c'est une femme sur deux qui se sont
victime d'une discrimination sans
oublier bien sûr les discriminations sur
les origines là c'est une étude qui
disait que un candidat d'origine
maghrbine avait 50 % de chance de moins
d'être reçu un entretien que si il avait
eu un nom français donc pourtant euh il
y a beaucoup de gouvernements et depuis
longtemps ont fait des efforts pour
lutter contre la discrimination tion
dans ce pays mais on trouve on a du mal
à trouver la bonne méthode donc en 2009
c'était donc sous Nicolas Sarkozy le
gouvernement avait testé le CV anonyme
pour mettre tous les candidats sur un
pied d'égalité bon malheureusement il
semblerait que ça produisait l'effet
inverse de celui escomé donc ça a été
annulé il y a eu ensuite lors du plus
récemment donc du dernier premier
quinquen du précédent quinquen
d'Emmanuel Macron une opération de
testing à grande échelle qui avait été
lancé pour voir si les grandes
entreprises traitaient de manière égale
des des candidats de régines différentes
ça avait conduit donc à Sep entreprises
épingl le fameux na mhem on vous fait
honte pour vous changiez votre
comportement sauf que là en fait
beaucoup d'entreprises n'étaient pas
d'accord surtout Air France qui était
très remonté contre ce le résultat et
qui avait mis en en évidence le fait que
les méthodes étaient vraiment pas du
tout fiabl et donc ça faussait le
résultat c'est donc pour ça que Marc
Ferraci et là dit ça suffffit maintenant
on doit quand même pouvoir s'organiser
sur ce sur ce sujet donc créer un
service auprès de la première ministre
qui déjà devrait permettre de mettre au
point des tests fiables sur lesquels
tout le monde soit d'accord qui
permettrait donc de tester à grande
échelle un très grand nombre
d'entreprise pour traquer celles qui
pratiquent la discrimination et
évidemment éventuellement les
sanctionner avec un autre avantage aussi
qui serait des tests individuels vous
avez eu le sentiment d'être discriminé
et bien on peut faire un test et si le
test est positif ça facilitera le fait
de pouvoir porter plainte contre cette
discrimination alors il y a d'autres
détails on va sans doute les découvrir
pendant le débat juste avant je voudrais
vous rappeler une étude qui a été mené
par France stratégie en 2016 et qui
expliquait que notre économie se prive
de nombreux talents avec les
discrimination et que en se privant de
ces talent et bien elle perd jusqu'à
entre 4 et 14 % de son PIB donc c'est un
chiffre absolument énorme donc je vous
propose d'écouter ce que disait mirriam
elcomery à l'époque ministre du Travail
qui elle aussi avait lancé son plan
antidiscrimination les discriminations
c'est une faute morale une injustice
sociale mais c'est aussi une aberération
économique France stratégie notamment
les discriminations que subissent les
femmes ou les personnes originaires
d'Afrique ou de l'Outre Mer quelque part
ça coûte à la collectivité près de 150
milliards voilà ce qu' a indiqué hier
France stratégique vous avez donc bien
entendu supprimer les discrimination ça
pourrait rapporter 150 milliards de
richesse supplémentairire alors qu'on
attend la notation de instard pour
franchement c'est 150 milliards c'est
merci beaucoup merci Stéphane pierre
ferra c'est vrai qu'on est un peu sur
Mar décidément je vous ai dit Pierre
tout à l'heure non non Marc tout à
l'heure oui excusez-moi bon ben voilà
c'est bien il y a le père et le fils
Marc j'avais écrit pierre pardon est-ce
que il y a pas une forme d'échec on est
6 ans après l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron
sur son objectif principal c'est-à-dire
la fin de l'assignation à résidence
l'égalité des chances l'émancipation par
le travail on est 6 ans après vous
portez un texte c'est une forme voilà de
de difficulté voir d'échec le vôtre bon
il y a un échec qui est celui de plus de
20 ans de politique de lutte contre les
discriminations ça a été rappelé en 2016
il y a eu des initiatives des testings
on va en reparler il y a une législation
et ça a aussi été très bien dit qui
remonte au début des années 2000 qui a
permis notamment de valider le principe
des tests comme un outil de preuve dans
le cadre d'une action en justice il y a
ces 25 critères qui ont été
progressivement rajoutés dans la loi et
donc on a un arsenal juridique qui
aujourd'hui produit très peu d'effets je
voudrais rappeler ou ajouter un chiffre
à ce qui a été dit en 2020 il y a eu
zéro zéro condamnation pénale en matière
de discrimination en France zéro ça veut
dire que concrètement alors que beaucoup
de personnes se sentent discriminées et
sont objectivement victimes de
discrimination parce qu'on le voit on
fait des testings en population générale
notamment qui le démontrre ça signifie
que ce droit à la réparation il est
inopérant et ça signifie aussi que les
comportements des acteurs que ce soit
les entreprises ou les administrations
ne fonctionnent pas donc il y a
évidemment une forme d'échec est-ce que
c'est l'échec de ce qui s'est passé
depuis 2017 moi je suis prêt tout à fait
fait à remettre en question ce qui a été
fait bien fait mal fait on a fait on a
fait des testings et l'un a été
mentionné depuis 2017 qui n'ont pas
produit les effets escomptés et une
partie du contenu de la proposition de
loi que je porte vise justement à tirer
les enseignements de ces échecs d'accord
mais vous croyez encore à la loi c'est
intéressant parce qu'on peut se dire
aussi que après tout ça la loi ne change
rien cro parce que c'est une loi et je
vais laisser évidemment la parole à mes
à mes à mes collègues c'est une loi qui
ne rajout pas à l'arsenal juridique
c'est une loi qui vise à le rendre plus
opératoire en faisant plus de tests et
en essayant de manière très concrète de
changer les comportements alors le
testing vous vous connaissez bien à SOS
racine ça fait des années hein qu'on
parle de ce sujet ça fait des années
qu'on voit des reportages avec des
militants d' SOS qui passent des coups
de fil qui vont faire des caméras
cachées et qui montrent les
discriminations dans dans dans ce pays
vous y croyez à cet outil là ah on y
croit à l'outil du testing parce que
c'est ce qui permet que derrière ça
change ou pas c'est ça les
discriminations raciales parce que
souvent on vous dit bah ça n'existe pas
ou alors c'est le fait de quelques
personnes très idéologiques qui vont
refuser des noirs ou des Arabes dans
leur entreprise ça n'est pas ça la
réalité la réalité c'est que c'est un
phénomène qui est relativement massif
qui pourrit la vie des gens et le
testing permet d'objectiver justement
les discriminations qui sont souvent des
comportements qui ne sont pas verbalisés
on vous dit rarement je ne vais pas vous
louer cet appartement parce que vous
êtes noir vous n'aurez pas cet emploi
parce que vous êtes Arab donc le
problème c'est pas le testing c'est les
leçons on tire c'est les leçons qu'on en
tire et là c'est vrai que historiquement
on a eu au début des années 2000 plutôt
des pouvoirs publics qui ont pris en
charge les choses il y a eu la création
de la Hal il y a une visibilité qui a
été donnée une évolution de la
jurisprudence Marc ferci le rappel suite
au testing de SOS Racisme la Cour de
cassation a reconnu par exemple le
testing comme une méthode de preuve
valable devant les tribunaux
malheureusement on a vu pendant de
grandes années une éclipse du sujet qui
revient un peu ces dernières années nous
même on a relancé des grandes campagnes
de testing dans l'immobilier dans
l'emploi euh et oui ça peut faire bouger
les choses à part que la question des
discriminations pour que ça bouge ça
n'est pas se mobiliser pendant 2
semaines ou 3 semaines c'est quelque
chose qui vraiment s'inscrit dans la
durée parce qu'en fait ça interroge des
pratiques et les pratiques pour les
changer ça prend du temps juste pour
nous situer c'est pas évident d'avoir
des chiffres hein sur les
discriminations les statistiques
certaines statistiques ethniques sont
sont sont interdites est-ce qu'on est un
peu comment dire quand on on part on se
console par rapport à d'autres pays
européens ou est-ce qu'on est les pires
en Europe est-ce qu'on on sait ça ou pas
je je sais pas c'est toujours compliqué
à savoir mais de toute façon ce qui est
sûr c'est que quand même il y a un
principe d'égalité en France il n'est
pas effectif la République c'est il faut
toujours la voir comme une promesse
inachevée la question c'est comment on
fait en sorte qu'elle soit davantage
achevée bah il y a du boulot faisons-le
chez nous et puis pour les autres pays
bah ils pouront peut-être s'inspirer de
ce qu'on fait ici on va rentrer dans le
détail Stéphanie lecer ça fait des
années qu'on parle du sujet les
entreprises elles sont souvent pointées
du R dooit on entend en des Air France
qui disait c'est pas moi c'est
l'indicateur c'est mal fichu on peut pas
faire confiance à à tous les outils
qu'on a pour essayer de de les trraquer
ces discriminations on sait si les
entreprises sont plus vertueuses
aujourd'hui ou ça empire avec les années
al j'espère que ça empire pas avec les
années je pense qu'il y a une grosse
prise de conscience sur le sujet des
discriminations dans l'emploi depuis une
vingtaine d'années on a un certain
nombre d'entreprises qui sont très
mobilisées sur le sujet qui lancent des
plans d'action qui ont des politiques
d'inclusion qui sont très engagé mais on
on réalise encore que il y a des sujets
sur lesquels on a du mal à progresser
les chiffres les études sont là et la
discrimination elle existe toujours
lesquel précisément bah tout les études
que vous venez de citer enfin si je
prends la dernière mais les domaines sur
lesquels les discriminations n'arrive
pas à progresser c'est lesquels c'est
les discriminations al sur le sur le en
fonction de quel critère principalement
alors on on voit qu'il y a des
progressions dans le domaine du genre
des femmes par exemple sur l'origine je
trouve qu'on a énormément de mal à
progresser sur la question des seiors on
a beaucoup beaucoup de mal à progresser
aussi donc il y a une prise de
conscience il y a des actions qui sont
faites par les entreprises qu'il
faudrait plus communiquer he nous on
essae au niveau des association de
mettre en avant les entreprises qui ont
des politiques plutôt engagé sur le
sujet à la fois de la lutte contre les
discrimination et la promotion de la
diversité hein parce que c'est un tout
et pour nous quand on voit l'ensemble
des études qui sont publiées aujourd'hui
je pense à la dernière de la dars sur le
fait que malgré un niveau de diplôme
équivalent des personnes d'origine
étrangère avec le même diplôme en France
ou à l'étranger ça change rien ont
beaucoup plus de chance d'être
discriminé que des personnes qui
seraient originaires de France ou qui
aurait un nom à consonance européenne on
voit que effectivement le testing c'est
un outil qui doit être utilisé par les
entreprises mais comme partie beaucoup
plus large une politique de lutte contre
les discriminations si c'est un outil
unique et que ça vise juste à contrôler
une infime partie des process de
recrutement ou d'évolution de carrière
là effectivement ça va être on va
regarder dans le détail qui ferait ce
testing à qui serait confié et et pour
déboucher sur quoi dans un instant quand
même Mousa Camara c'est plus dur de
s'appeler Moussa quand on cherche du
travail que de s'appeler Marc
franchement bien évidemment aujourd'hui
on est je pense queautour de la table on
est tous d'accord pour dire que nous
évoluons dans une société où la
discrimination ne devrait pas exister
tout simplement aujourd'hui elle existe
et euh ce que rappelait Monsieur le
Député Marc c'était de de dire que
finalement les condamnations étaient
quasiment nul et ça crée un sentiment
d'injustice pour la plupart des
personnes qui sont discriminées oou à un
moment donné il y a énormément de
discrimination qu'on VO qu'on voit pas
forcément ou qu'on va pas forcément
signaler parce que finalement c'est
devenu normal on a tous vécu des
situations parfois quand on cherchait un
emploi ou un logement ou même pour avoir
accès un certains lieux où il y a eu
sentiment de de de de discrimination
mais on en parle pas on le garde pour
nous et c'est vous vous AZ fait
déterminer pardonnez-moi je je vous
laisse termin ouais mais le danger il
est là nous quand on crée aujourd'hui un
projet comme les déterminé c'est pour
permettre à toutes celles et ceux qui se
sentent parfois bloqués par quelque
chose donc vous contournez en fait de
pouir en fait' l'idée c'est devenir
employeur c'est ça votre histoire c'est
pas l'idée de Dir ur au fond essayé de
contourner la montagne de CV pas
forcément parce que c'est une
réponse c'est pas forcément une seule
réponse à la discrimination mais ça peut
aussi palier à ça quand on voit que
certains n'arrivent pas forcément à
trouver le job qui dans
lequel il rêve bah finalement il y a
d'autres moyens détourner de créer sa
boîte de développer son business et
cetera mais tout le monde n'a pas cette
capacité tout le monde n'ura jamais
cette détermination de créer une
entreprise alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour celles et ceux qui veulent juste
rentrer dans un emploi s'épanouir
évoluer et là il y que vous vous avez
créé votre entreprise de bac en poche
hein à 18 ans la première donc voilà ça
raconte aussi c'est évidemment une
détermination une envie mais c'est pas
facile j'ai fait des erreurs et en plus
résultat d'une situation et la réussite
elle est pas garantie pour tous les
entrepreneurs au final il y a certains
qui réussissent d'autres qui qui
échouent et c'est une réalité et là où
il faut travailler pour moi et la loi
elle doit être importante en en
collaboration avec les entreprises et
les acteurs de terrain quotidiennement
ceux qui qui vivent auprès des des gens
qui sont discriminés bah c'est de de
faire en sorte que les entreprises
aujourd'hui elles comprennent que
finalement elles peuvent plus faire
comme elles faisaient depuis des années
pourquoi parce que déjà il y a un
de de de de moyens humains dans dans les
dans plusieurs métiersù vous arri pas à
palier métion pas que les métiers à
attention mais aussi en terme de
symbolique la plupart des clientèles je
parleis avec une grande un grand groupe
de la distribution il disait que la
plupart de nos clients c'est des gens
qui sont quasiment pratiquement tous
issus de l'immigration mais dans
nos équipes généralement quand on monte
au niveau supérieur c'est uniquement des
gens qui se ressemblent et du coup
comment on arrive à m de mobiliser donc
elles ont compris qu'il y a un enjeu
fort de pouvoir aussi avoir plus de
représentativité làdessus et ça c'est un
sujet sur lequel au-delà des alors on y
va sur le texte on va essayer de
comprendre comment vous voulez les
mettre un peu s surveillance les
entreprises pour parvenir à des
comportement plus vertueux mais pour se
figurer les choses on part sur le
terrain grâce aux équipes de France
Télévision la caméra n'est pas visible
la discrimination elle elle saute aux
yeux regardez c'est un reportage de
France
Télévision
un nom étranger une couleur de peau
peuvent barrer l'accès au logement la
discrimination cet étudiant dit en avoir
été victime il postulait pour une
colocation avec une amie portant un nom
à consonance française le gestionnaire
semble prêt à signé quand tout s'arrête
il reçoit la carte d'identité de ma
colocataire la mère de ma colocataire
bah du coup la mienne moi riad et celle
de mon père Mohamed et c'est à ce
momentl qui devient de plus en plus
réticent qui commence à dire oui mais
ils sont jeunes jusqu'au jour on arrive
la veille de la signature et c'est à ce
momentl qu'il nous dit on annule tout
selon une enquête de SOS Racisme 25 %
des agences immobilières sont prêtes à
refuser certains profils à la demande
des propriétaires en caméra cachée nous
nous rendons dans quatre agences nous
affirmons avoir un studio à louer l'une
des agences se dit prête à faire le tri
entre les candidats en fonction de leur
origine
oui mais faut je peux pas leur dire ça
comme ça mais effectivement je leur dis
écoutez espondait pas au profil du
propriétaire les les rouenus sont pas
suffisants on pas de faire ce genre de
discrimination mais je défend les
intérêt du propriétaire donc moi je
sélectionne dans mon co personne ne sera
une discrimination interdite par la loi
passible de 3 ans de prison et 45000 €
d'amende pourtant chaque jour des
victimes appellent le Défenseur des
droits sur une ligne dédiée un homme se
plaint d'avoir vu son dossier rejeté par
un propriétaire il demande alors à sa
compagne de se porter à son tour
candidate et donc elle se présente bien
ma compine est française donc il lui
répond directement il lui dit écoutez il
y a pas de souci on peut faire une
visite à tout moment la part est
disponible la plupart des dossiers se
traitent par la médiation d'autres vont
jusqu'en justice un combat essentiel
pour la Défenseur des droits les
discriminations sont délétaires pour les
personnes qui en sont victimes ça
atteint leur santé physique mentale ça
pe leur parcours professionnel enfin et
puis quand on n pas de logement quand on
a du mal à obtenir un logement comment
on peut se stabiliser dans la vie
aujourd'hui en c très peu de victimes de
discrimination osent demander de l'aide
et déposer plainte voilà si on prend ce
reportage très concrètement on est sur
les discrimination au logement il y a
les agences immobilières puis il y a les
propriétaires derrière qu'est-ce que
pourrait changer cette proposition de
loi al déjà moi je veux rebondir sur ce
qu'a dit Moussa Camara et ce qui vient
d'être dit il y a un sentiment contre
lequel il faut absolument lutter c'est
le sentiment de résignation il y a
beaucoup de gens qui se résignent qui
savent qu' sont en situation de
discrimination et qui passent à autre
chose qui vont vers une autre offre d'
on pourrait faire une offre une autre
offre de logement ça il faut lutter
contre ça pour ça il faut faire deux
choses il faut essayer d'agir sur les
comportements il faut essayer d'offrire
un droit à la réparation qui soit plus
effectif on en a parlé tout à l'heure il
y a trop peu de recours en justice il y
a trop peu d'utilisation des tests
individuels qui sont un élément de
preuve aujourd'hui qui est admis par le
code pénal alors expliquez-nous le test
individuel parce que ça c'est un des
éléments le
test'est c'est un test c'est au fond
envoyer des candidatures similaires qui
ne se distingue que par un critère de
discrimination c'est-à-dire un âge
différent un patronyme différent
maghrébin ou français des candidatures
similaires qui peuvent être des
candidature à l'emploi au logement à un
prêt bancaire et la proposition que je
porte embrasse tous ces sujets c'est pas
uniquement une proposition sur les
discrimination à l'embauche ça touchera
et ça permettra de faire des tests sur
notamment le sujet du logement ensuite
on distingue effectivement dans cette
proposition deux types de tests des
tests massifs ou qu'on appelle aussi des
tests statistiques qui consistent le
plus souvent à envoyer des candidatures
fic vous allez envoyer à un employeur
des CV fictifs qui se distinguent par le
critère de discrimination alors ça pour
bien comprendre ça sera à Matignon la
dilcra c'est ça la Délégation
interministérielle de lut contre le
racismeou plutôt on va étendre les
mission de la dilkra qui existe déjà à
la lutte contre les discriminations et
on lui donne des moyens pour faire
notamment des tests statistiques les
tests statistiques il porent sur des
candidatures fictives et donc il y a pas
de personne réelle qui a subi un
préjudice donc on ne peut pas sur la
base d'un test statistique aller en
justice en revanche ce qu'on peut faire
ce que se propose de faire la
proposition de loi c'est de publier les
résultats des tests si les entreprises
ou les administrations parce que là
aussi la proposition de loi n'est pas
uniquement sur le secteur privé il y a
aussi le secteur publicique qui doit
être exemplaire on publie les résultats
si les acteurs qui ont été testés
positifs n'engagent pas des actions
efficaces pour limiter les
discriminations c'est ce qu'on appelle
le l shame et cette proposition loi va
encadrer juridiquement déjà donner une
base juridique au neon ch qui n'existe
pas aujourd'hui parce qu' aujourd'hui
une entreprise dont on publie le nom et
c'était le cas vous en avez parlé d'Air
France elle réagit très mal et parfois
elle veut faire un recours en justice
contre les chercheurs qui ont fait le
testing et ça on veut l'éviter on veut
sécuriser la publication des résultats
et donc crédibiliser cette menace mais
en même temps on veut accompagner ça a
été dit par Moussa on veut accompagner
les acteurs dans le changement de leur
comportement et notamment les outiller
avec un certain nombre d'actions parmi
les actions certaines fait l'objet
d'expérimentation le CV anonyme donc je
pourrais dire que l'expérimentation qui
a été faite est pas tout à fait
concluante mais il faudrait la refaire
parce qu'elle a été fait dans des
conditions étranges mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que compris c'est très bien
c'est le test statistique ensuite le
test individuel c'est l'autre objectif
et j'irai plus vite c'est de donner aux
personnes un droit à la réparation
aujourd'hui des tests individuels au
fond beaucoup d'acteurs peuvent en faire
la Défenseur des droits qui été cité ici
peut en faire les associations peuvent
en faire des avocats pour le compte de
leurs clients peuvent en faire donc avec
ce avec ce texte là vous allez pouvoir
générer on va pouvoir en faire plus mais
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'un test individuel est fait par une
personne réelle et pas par une personne
fictive et parce qu'il est fait par une
personne réelle il peut être utilisé
dans le cadre d'une action en justice le
but c'est de faire plus de test STATIS
et plus de test individuel toujours la
dilcra en N et pour le compte des
personnes associations avocats qui
souhaitent en faire et qui n'en ont pas
toujours les moyens c'est ça qui bien
compris Dominique Sopo quel est votre
sentiment sur ces deux jambes en fait un
gros massif qui serait fait par des
chercheurs après appel d'offre confié à
la à la dilcra pour arriver à changer
comportement et si on n arrive pas
sanction financière ou nachem et puis la
possibilité d'une sorte de statut de
victime de discrimination qui pourrait
valoir de preuve devant les tribunaux
oui de toute façon tout ce qui permet de
faire davantage de testing pour
objectiver les discriminations qui sont
faites globalement dans la société ou
dont des personnes ont été
individuellement victimes de toute façon
c'est une bonne chose et on ne peut que
soutenir cela euh évidemment comment
dire quand on est associatif on constate
aussi qu'il y a d'autres problématiques
c'est que notamment aujourd'hui il y a
certes la difficulté d'apporter la
preuve euh or le testing c'est bien cela
ce que je disais tout à l'heure quand
vous êtes victime de discrimination il y
a rarement quelqu'un qui vous dit je ne
vous prends pas parce que vous appelez
Mohamed hein c'est très rare ça peut
arriver mais c'est très rare bon donc il
faut bien objectiver pour se faire euh
j'allais dire pour que justice soit
faite ceci étant évidemment et on en a
discuté il faut aussi que la chaîne
pénale soit beaucoup plus sensibilisée
qu'elle ne l' aujourd'hui parce que
aujourd'hui pour avoir une condamnation
pour discrimination il faut que déjà
vous tombez vous tombiez sur des
personnes qui sont sensibles au sujet
quand vous allez porter plainte que
l'enquête soit faite que on n pas des
des classements sans suite à répétition
et que à la fin il y a une peine à peu
près crédible qui soit et dissuasive qui
soit prononcé je peux vous dire qu'en
France quand on regarde la rigueur avec
la qu les preuves pour discrimination
sont appréciées par la justice cétait le
cas pour tous les délits du code pénal
nos prisons elles seraient très vides
donc il y a aussi un effort en parallèle
à faire alors qu'il là ne dépend pas de
la proposition de lo comment expliquer
ça les magistrat soi pas sensibilisés
c'est
quoi il faut être formé il faut être
sensibilisé il faut se dire que ça vaut
le coup il faut comprendre que c'est
grave c'est pas c'est pas si évident
vous savez il y a d'autres délits
pendant très longtemps quand vous étiez
femmes et que vous alliez devant la
police pour dire que vous aviez été
victime par votre mari comment dire
d'une claque trop appuyée bon autant
vous dire que ça ne déclenchait pas
grand-chose en matière en matière pénale
donc il y a quand même cette dimension
parce que là il y a des espoirs qui sont
soulevés et bien j'espère que ça va
aussi être un effet de levier par
rapport peut-être dire au ministère de
la Justice ministère de l'INT
association dit c'est le début de
quelque chose je pense que on disait
tout à l'heure il y a pas il y a pas une
solution magique il y a pas une solution
magique et juste une petite un petit
quelque chose pour montraer comment dire
la difficulté dans quelques semaines
nous aurons un procès contre adeco sur
des faits premier employeur de France
adco he sur des faits qui remontent à
quasiment un quart de siècle parce que
il y a eu des classements sans suite à
répétition que heureusement il y a
d'autres magistrat qui ont dit non c'est
pas possible il faut qu'il y ait un
procès vous rendez compte un quart de
siècle parce que nous on est là on on
est encore là un quart de siècle plus
tard après avoir porté plainte
franchement un individu bien s c'est
beaucoup trop long un quart de siècle et
par ailleurs je j'espère que quelqu'un
qui est dans cette situation j'espère
presque pour lui qu'il aura lâché avant
parce que il y a de quoi devenir fou
Stéphanie leer vous regardez comment ce
ce texte vous représentez à la fois les
entreprises dans ce débat mais vous
votre boulot c'est de faire matcher les
recruteurs avec ceux qui recherchent un
emploi donc voilà vous êtes active dans
l'idée même que on lutte contre les les
discriminations c'est un premier pas où
c'est toute la société et ça ça prendra
du temps qu'il faut faire évoluer non je
crois que c'est un premier pas nous ce
ce principe de testing c'est un c'est un
outil et un principe qu'on défend et
qu'on promut depuis des années il y a
énormément d'entreprises qui font déjà
du testing sollicité c'est-à-dire que
elles demande à des prestataires
externes d'envoyer des CV différents
similaires pour voir si leurs propres
équipes leurs propres recruteurs ou
opérationnels vont recruter de manière
équilibrée et sans discrimination donc
c'est un outil vraiment dans une
politique de lutte cont contre les
discriminations qui peut être tout à
fait important par exemple vous avez
déjà été confronté à des demandeurs
d'emploi qui vous ont avoué de changer
leur nom tout simplement ou leur prénom
oui bien sûr oui oui qui vont voir si
finalement il y a un petit peu la la
même réaction parce que à un moment ils
vont être perdus et ils vont se dire
pourquoi mon CV n'obtient absolument
aucun retour aucune réponse et puis je
pense que voilà quand vous avez un
certain nombre de personnes qui sortent
d'une école d'un diplôme et qu'on voit
autour de soi tout le monde avoir des
entretiens et qu'avec un nom différent
ou avec une particularité différ
différente on nobtient pas de réponse on
a des
raisons c'est un outil qui est important
après nous ce sur quoi on insiste c'est
que ça peut pas être le seul pour
plusieurs raisons ça peut pas être le
seul déjà parce que sur des testings
statistiques on sait qu'on va viser
simplement une partie des entreprises il
faut savoir qu'il y a à peu près 70 %
des intentions d'embauche de 2022 c'est
des entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
donc elles peuvent pas faire l'objet de
de testing statistique pardon elles
peuvent faire l'objet de testing
individuel he bien évidemment mais ces
entreprises là on va pas forcément
pouvoir les les viser parce que sinon on
verra très très rapidement qu'il a un
testing c'est difficile de de pouvoir
utiliser cet outil et puis par ailleurs
on voit aussi que il y a énormément
d'autres modes de de de recrutement
aujourd'hui on en parlait tout à l'heure
à travers les réseaux sociaux ou
directement sur des base de données et
là on a absolument aucun moyen de
contrôler c'est ça c'est le recrutement
direct via des plateformes comme voilà
donc pour nous le testing c'est un très
bon outil mais ils doivent surtout pas
être l'arbre qui cache la forêt et
c'est-à-dire que il faut que
l'entreprise derrière elle s'engage sur
beaucoup plus d'actions à la fois pour
bien valider dans tous ces processus de
recrutement et d'évolution de carrière
que on va avoir des formations qui sont
extrêmement appuyées alors à différents
niveaux juridiques sur les biis sur les
comportements de l'ensemble des
personnes qui vont intervenir dans le
recrutement he pas seulement les
recruteurs mais aussi un certain nombre
d'acteurs dans l'entreprise et puis il
faut aussi absolument s'assurer que
l'ensemble des politiques après qui sont
mises en place dans l'entreprise vont
permettre une vraie politique
d'inclusion vont permettre une
traçabilité des candidatures une
traçabilité ensuite de la réussite dans
l'entreprise et un certain nom la porte
d'entrée vous voulez réagir Vincent
lumir oui oui benah enfin moi je suis
prof à l'Université enfin j'enseigne à
la fac depuis 25 ans et aujourd'hui je
suis prof à l'Université Gustave eel à
Marne laavallée donc j'ai une sociologie
j étaé aussi voilà m de r noisichamp
enfin voilà c'est un super campus on a
des supers étudiants mais voilà on a une
on a une sociologie très très très très
variée et évidemment pour nous pour elle
et eux pour pour les étudiantes les
étudiants c'est c'est c'est un sujet
hyper important l'insertion
professionnelle on a aussi plein plein
de de formations master en alternance
donc pro où ils sont une semaine en
entreprise une semaine avec nous et on
voit bien que même pour on parle
beaucoup mais même pour euh placer comme
on dit c'est-à-dire ces étudiants dans
des dans des entreprises bon bah parfois
c'est le sujet donc on on le voit euh on
est en première pu il faut que voilà et
puis l'autre l'autre point de vue c'est
c'est l'historien et c'est la question
de de l'échec alors moi je suis un peu
un indécrotable optimiste mais ce que je
vous entends la prise de conscience
verbalisation l'implicite l'explicite je
pense que c'est toujours il faut il faut
aussi juger enfin je veux dire ça
pourrait être pire si tout ce qui avait
été fait n'avait pas encore été fait
donc ça peut être aussi un échec relatif
je veux dire il y a déjà une prise de
conscience sur la question de la
verbalisation je P effectivement jamais
un employeur va dire je vous recrute pas
parce que vous êtes noir ou arabe mais
peut-être que même lui il se le dit pas
ouon sa bien donc c'est peut-être même
des fois une conscientisation
individuelle et là c'est encore plus
profond et donc il faut travailler
encore plus à la question en
percollation ouais ouais c'est il va pas
le dire parce qu'en fait il le sait même
pas lui-même il veut pas se l'avouer
donc ce que je veux dire c'est que cette
phase de prise de conscience enfin ce
qu'on est en train de faire là y compris
législative et tout elle va finir par
avoir des effets je je dirais par
infusion par percolation là c'est
l'historien qui parle parce que voilà
c'est le temps un peu long c'est ce
qu'on a dit et puis le le et puis le
multifacteur le multicritère mais c'est
le genre de sujet sur lesquel on VO bien
faut tenir fort et longtemps quoi ça ça
c'est très vrai très rapidement les
situations de discrimination qui sont
révélées par des testings elles
traduisent très rarement des
discriminations volontaires et assumées
c'est souvent des représentations qui
sont biaisées on va considérer qu'un
jeune des quartier a pas les codes pour
s'insérer dans un collectif de travail
on va considérer que c'est plus
sécurisant de recruter des gens qui sont
issus de notre école de l'école qu'on a
faite quand on avait quand on avait 20
ans moi-même j'étais responsable de
Master dans la même université et
j'étais vra vraiment confronté à cette
problématique on voyait qu'il y avait
des difficultés spécifiques pour
s'insérer pour les étudiants issus de
l'immigration et donc l'enjeu c'est
effectivement et là je rejoins
totalement ce qui a été dit c'est pas de
miser uniquement sur le testing moi je
le dis je l'ai dit en commission des
lois le testing c'est pas la recette
miracle ça s'inscrit dans une stratégie
globale qui mèle la sensibilisation les
actions de formation des processus qui
peut-être doivent évoluer dans certaines
entreprises notamment le recrutement
sans CV peut-être retester le CV anonyme
et puis j'ajoute un élément
très important parce que ça c'est ce qui
est devant nous dans les prochaines
années c'est que le testing il est aussi
utile pour repérer les billets
discriminatoires qui proviennent de
l'utilisation des algorithmes de recr
oui alors justement je vis qu'on termine
làdessus qu'est-ce que vous dites juste
accz donc parce qu'elle est pas contente
la Défenseur des droits elle dit
attention vous donnez celle à dilc et
Matignon et si demain je ne sais pas des
populistes Marine Le Pen gagnait les
élections est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
lui confier cette lutte contre
discrimination a cette discusion c'est
indépendant comme j'ai fait cette
réponse d'abord sur le sujet testing
statistique elle a fourni en tant que
défenseur des droits un avis qui est
plutôt en soutien de la proposition de
loi sur le testing individuel moi ce que
je dis simplement c'est que on peut pas
se satisfaire du statut quo le statut
quo c'est encore une fois quasiment
aucune condamnation pénale et c'est très
très peu de tests individuels y compris
réalisé par la défense de droit je dis
juste un truc c'est que si Marine Le Pen
ou l'extrême droite arrive au pouvoir en
2027 on aura des sujets un petit peu
plus graves à gérer que le sujet de la
répartition des compétences entre la
dilcra et défense monous Camara je vais
vous donner le le mot de la fin c'est
vrai qu'on entre dans dans le monde de
l'IA ou demain ou même déjà on a des
algorithme qui recrute en fonction d'un
certain nombre de de critères parfois
ils sont vendus ces algorithmes parfois
ils sont même fabriqués par par les
boîtes il est pas déjà dépassé ce ce
débat je pense pas qu'il est dépassé
parce que le temps que tout ça ça se met
en place il y a encore un travail à
faire on le voit que les choses bougent
de manière très lente très très lente
moi depuis que je suis je suis petit
j'entends ces histoires de de
discrimination j'ai l'impression que 30
ans plus tard ça a pas forcément plus
avancé que ça donc la réalité
c'est-à-dire avec ses outils qui peuvent
aussi faciliter un certain nombre de
choses comment aujourd'hui on arrive à
faire en sorte que ces outils de l'IA et
tout et cetera soient pas plus
discriminant pour des personnes euh qui
sont déjà discriminé donc ça fait
plaisir tout le monde opine du chef tout
le monde est d'accord et pour une fois
malgré l'absence de majorité absolue
quelque chose me dit que ce texte a
toutes les chances d'être adopté on va
le suivre évidemment ce débat
parlementaire à partir de de lundi merci
à vous merci on s'arrête là merci d'être
venu débattre sur LCP vous restez avec
moi Vincent Lemire dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nous
affranchis ce soir Léa Falco nous parle
du plan biodiversité de la France
présenté à la COP 28 de Dubaï ultra
c'est évidemment le mot de la semaine de
Mariette d'iggrand avec ses
manifestations de l'ultra droite et puis
ça achauffit hier soir à l'Assemblée
Marco Pomier oui myiam Hugo bernalicis
l'insoumis a a été durement sanctionné
par yel brun pivé vous verrez à tout à
l'heure les amis mais d'abord on va
parler du conflit Israël à Mass avec
vous Vincent Lemire l'historien que vous
êtes le suit au jour le jour on a besoin
de comprendre on a besoin du recul de
l'histoire on témoigne le phénomène de
librairie de votre album magnifique
histoire de Jérusalem déjà 100000
exemplaires vendus c'est dire à quel
point la demande de donner un peu de de
profondeur et de recul est nécessaire au
moment où on apprend ce matin la trêve
élevée en Israël on regarde ça dans
l'invitation de Marco Pomier et on en
parle tous les deux juste après si on
vous invite Vincent Lemire c'est pour
avoir l'analyse de l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes de la guerre entre Israël
et la Palestine guerre sanglante 56
jours de conflit plus de 15000 morts
dans la bande de Gaza terrible bilan de
l'opération militaire israélienne après
la sauvagerie du octobre et les
massacres du Hamas 1200 morts en
quelques heures seulement il y a aucun
précédent on est dans le 5e acte du du
conflit Israël au palestinien dans la
tragédie grecque le 5èe acte c'est
l'acte du dénouement qui mieux que vous
Vincent Lemire pour nous parler de ce
conflit complexe passionnel vous
l'historien vous l'ancien directeur du
centre de recherche français à Jérusalem
auteur de plusieurs ouvrage sur cette
ville trois fois sainte Jérusalem témoin
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui desespoir de pai
des tensions communautaires et des
épisodes meurtriers un siècle
d'affrontement 5 juin à l'aube les
avions israéliens foncent sur les
objectifs militaires d'Égypte de Syrie
et de Jordanie de la guerre des 6 jours
à celle de Gaza sans oublier la guerre
du Kipour ou la première Intifada de
1987 date de la création du Hamas
l'histoire retiendra aussi cette
tentative de paix ratée poignée de main
historique d'un côté itsak Rabin Premier
ministre israélien de l'autre Yasser
Arafat à la tête de l'Organisation de
Libération de la Palestine
1995 Rabin est assassiné les fameux
accords d'Oslo ne seront jamais
respectés je suis très triste c'est une
lourde faute àortter pour Israël ce
meurtre de Rabine et plus encore parce
que c'est un Israélien
commis une paix impossible alors que les
combatsent après une semaine de trêve et
la libération de plusieurs dizaines
d'otages 150 sont encore retenu
l'angoisse se prolonge pour leur famille
notamment pour celle du petit kirbibas
ce bébé âgé de 10 mois seulement le
Hamas a annoncé sa mort son histoire
traumatise tout un pays plus polarisé
que jamais alors ce soir Vincent Lemire
on a une question pour vous l'État
hébreu a-t-il une véritable stratégie
militaire n'assistons-nous pas à une
fuite en avant
oui
réponse depuis le depuis le 8 octobre on
dit que que c'est un piège
euh j'ai écrit dès le le 9 10 octobre
donc vraiment on était tout près de
l'événement que c'est un piège tendu par
le par le Hamas qui n'attendait que la
roste c'est ça ouais est tendu à ce
gouvernement-l hein parce que c'est un
gouvernement bien particulier quand même
hein et c'est pas toute la société
israélienne qui qui est complexe qui
danst une partie s'est fortement
mobilisé contre ce gouvernement pour sa
faillite sécuritaire avant même le 7
octobre pendant de nombreux mois
nombreux mois avec on a eu il y a eu
certains jours il y avait 500000 600000
manifestants dans les rues israéliennes
à l'échelle française ça veut dire 5
millions de personnes il faut se rendre
compte de ce que ce que c'était donc
c'est un piège qui a été tendu à ce
gouvernement là à ce premier ministre là
qui manque totalement de de leadership
et de lucidité et qui fait dans un
moment de crise existentielle majeure
pour
l'état de la politique de la petite
politique quelle lecture vous faites de
de la reprise des combats cette fin de
trêve elle a été annoncée ce matin par
l'État hébreu après une nouvelle salve
de roquette tirée par le Hamas depuis la
bande de de Gaza surtout après la non
livraison d'otage ça devait être que des
femmes par le Hamas Israël a bombardé il
faut voir sur la carte à la fois le Nord
et le Sud ranones mais aussi Rafa ainsi
que le nord du pays et chacun se renvoie
la responsabilité aujourd'hui c'est un
retour en arrière totale non c'est pas
un retour à la situation d'avant la
trêve on ne reviendra pas à la situation
d'avant la trêve parce que la trêve
s'est bien passée elle a été plus longue
que prévu elle a été sérieuse elle a été
crédible les différents acteurs dans la
négociation ont tenu parole les listes
d'otage était strictement respecté les
heures de libération le nombre de
camions et même les difficultés qu'il y
a eu dans la trêve le deuxè jour le
samedi où on a eu un retard c'est parce
que voilà le le le Hamas disait non mais
on veut vérifier que les camions et
cetera donc je dirais même que les
difficultés un peu les les rugosités
dans la trêve pour moi sont un signe de
sérieux et de et de crédibilité on ne
reviendra pas en arrière on a aussi une
branche politique du Hamas au Qatar qui
a repris un petit peu la main sur sa
branche militaire à Gaza ça il faut
l'expliquer mais oui parce que vous
faites une distinction très claire entre
lestin alors dans tous les mouvements
moi j'ai dès le 7 octobre dès le 8
octobre he j'ai dit c'est un acte
terroriste non seulement terroriste mais
horrifique et ça fait partie de la
stratégie d'avoir voulu terroriser et
horrifier pour créer cette réaction il y
a pas de sujet dessus par contre dans
tous les mouvements terroristes il y a
une branche politique et une branche
militaire et ne ser-ce que pour des
raisons de sécurité et opérationnell on
ne prépare pas une opération comme celle
du 7 octobre en en discutant en
assemblée générale ou au bureau
politique si vous voulez parce que parce
que parce queil y a des parce que tout
le monde est surveillé donc on savait
dès le 7 octobre B soir que la branche
politique n'était pas au courant des
détails de l'opération du 7 c'est donc
une opération de la branche militaire et
des d'un tout petit nombre de personnes
à Gaza ça c'était clair on le savait ce
qu'on savait pas c'est comment est que
la branche politique avait allait
pouvoir reprendre la main la négociation
de cette trêve le fait qu'elle se soit
bien passée que des prisonniers des
prisonnières palestiniennes aient été
libéré que d'une certaine manière les
habitants de Gaza ont pu respirer
pendant 8 jours c'est un gain politique
pour la branche politique et ça c'est un
acquis si vous voulez et c'est un acquis
pour la suite aussi il était certain que
cette rêve à un moment s'épuiserait dans
ses paramètres de départ hein
c'est-à-dire que il faut à la fois que
le Hamas puisse
localiser et sécuriser les assez assez
dotage et puis il faut que nathania
tienne son gouvernement sauf que là il y
a le le bébé de 10 moisfir dont le
visage a fait le tour du monde sa
famille son frère la mort a été annoncée
on sait que c'est un traumatisme pour
Israël et et et on a aussi cette
attentat à Jérusalem revendiqué par le
Hamas qui a fait trois morts on a
l'impression que c'est reparti vous vous
dites NON vous dites il y a le
porte-parole du gouvernement israélien
qui dit le Hamas va recevoir la pire des
raclé on est déjà selon le Hamas à plus
de 100 morts euh vous vous dites de
toute façon les choses ont changé c'est
ça non non mais le porte-parole il fait
de la politique enfin encore une fois il
parle à son opinion publique intérieure
faut pas être euh voilà il y a même il y
a des questions beaucoup plus là c'est
pas un Paris sur l'avenir que je fais il
y a
18800000 euh personnes euh
palestiniennes qui ont quitté le nord
pour le sud d'accord on leur a dit
quitte le Nord parce que elles sont au
sud Israël dit on va maintenant mener
les opération au sud ça veut dire qu'il
y a une densité encore plus forte au sud
qu'il y avait au nord donc on ne peut
pas aller chercher les terroristes les
un après les autres qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont dire repartez au nord c'est pas
possible il y a plus rien tout a été
détruit donc on voit bien que de toute
façon même sur le plan opérationnel et
même s'il le voulait et même sans
pression américaine l'armée israélienne
avec toute la meilleure volonté du monde
ne peut pas faire auuss une forme de
rationalité qui va finir il y a des
choses qui se passent il y a des choses
qui se passent sur le sur le terrain et
puis encore une fois il y a une opinion
publique israélienne y compris qui a
bougé c'est dire que c'est dans quel
sens et c'est terrible à dire mais cette
question des otages en fait elle a
permis j'allais dire à aux anciens enfin
aux opposants antiataniahou d'avant le 7
octobre de de ressémantiser ou en tout
cas de repolitiser le le débat en Israël
après le 7 octobre je m'explique est-ce
qu'il faut en priorité sauver les otages
ou est-ce qu'il faut en priorité
soi-disant éradiquer le Hamas
l'hypothèse de l'éradication du Hamas
s'éloigne les observateurs le disaient
dès le 8 mais on va dire même dans
l'opinion publique on comprend que on y
arrivera pas il va être affaibli mais
pas éradiqué et donc à l'inverse et on
voit que les otages on peut les faire
sortir donc on voit bien que c'est les
mêmes qui manifestent pour les otages et
qui manifestai contre netanahou vous
n'avez pas été capable de nous protéger
contre le 7 octobre au moins sauver les
otages c'est ça parce que vous vous
dites depuis le début je vous ai écouté
depuis le 8 octobre vous dites les
otages c'est la clé de ce conflit malgré
la reprise des combats vous le pensez
toujours les otages ça change tout 240
otages encore une fois à l'échelle de la
France il faut faire x 10 ça fait 2400
otages il faut se rendre compte en fait
de ce qui se passe donc c'est un
traumatisme mais dans la société civile
israélienne qui est majeure et c'est
transparti je dire gauche droite bien
sûr il y a quelques il y a il y a une
extrême extrême droite israélienne qui
qui joue qui joue contre la vie des
otages clairement en disant il faut pas
que les otages ralentissent le le le et
qui n'ont pas voté
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue là ils
sont en train de se faire cornériser
complètement c'estàdire que il y a même
des gens de droite en Israël qui disent
non là ils vont trop loin il faut aller
chercher les on connait Itamar bengv on
connaitar BV mais on connait moinsel
motric qui est bien plus dangereux que
Benv il fait beaucoup moins de bruit et
d'abord il est ministre des Finances il
a un portefeuille beaucoup plus large
ministre des Finances ministre de la
colonisation ceuxlà ils sont un peu
ostratisés aujourd'hui ostracisés je
dirais pas moi je dirais latéralisé
cornerérisé on va dire ils sont plus au
centre du jeu ils font tout pour essayer
de revenir au centre du jeu hein ils ont
poussé une loi antiterroriste
complètement à contetemp voilà mais mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que voilà il y
a des il y a des mouvements de bascule
il y a aussi une opinion publique
américaine qui joue il y a y compris une
diaspora juif-américaine qui n'est pas
du tout là où on pensait manifunis n'ont
jamais fa pression que voilà donc il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se sont passées
depuis le 7
octobre encore une fois vous allez me
trouver trop optimiste mais plutôt vers
le mieux voilà pour l'instant on n pas
de guerre encore au Liban ça alors que
c'était à deux doigts d'arriver on n pas
encore de frappe sur sur l'Iran et et on
a on va dire une reprise d'un processus
politique j'ai pas dit d'un processus de
négociation vers une solution j'ai dit
que des gens se parlent qui s'est
produite à Dubaï en marge de la COP 28
c'est celle du président israélien ITAC
Herzog et les mirire du Qatar altani euh
qui
discutent malgré euh la reprise des
combats la fin de la trêve des otages
donc ça vous l'interprétez comment
comment vous expliquez cette espèce de
paradoxe mais très clairement là on a le
président d'Israël qui discute avec
celui qui discute quasiment au au
téléphone avec Ismaël anier le
responsable de la branche politique du
Hamas il y a il y a qu'une personne en
fait entre le responsable de la branche
politique du Hamas et le président
d'Israël c'est le Pr Premier ministre
qatari c'est très proche et encore une
fois on est au Qatar les services
israéliens sont au Qatar depuis toujours
bien avant le 7 et bien après le 7 la
branche politique du Hamas y est ils se
connaissent par cœur je veux dire ils se
parlent au téléphone la question des
transferts de d'argent pour payer les
fonctionnaires à Gaza pour faire que
Gaza n'explose pas tout ça c'est avant
le 7 octobre tout n'a pas disparu le 7
octobre la situation est a été
complètement bouleversée il y a je suis
pas du tout moi j'ai toujours dit c'est
un méga événement c'est pas du tout
business as usual mais il y a aussi des
canaux qui existaient avant le 7 qui
existe toujours et ce que je veux dire
c'est que là on va plutôt
vers vers le mieux alors je dis ça je
peux être démenti dans 2 heures dans le
sens où ceux qui ne veulent pas que ça
aille vers le mieux des deux côtés
jjihad islamique par exemple dans la
bande de Gaza ou l'extrême extrême
droite en Israël peuvent faire en sorte
pendant qu'on se parle là de torpiller
le processus dont on est en train de
parler il y a une chose que de
l'extérieur on a du mal à comprendre
c'est comment Benyamine netaniaahou peut
encore piloter le pays le 8 octobre
toute la presse même la plus à droite en
Israël dénoncait son échec personnel et
on l'a vu il relance la colonisation en
sis Jordanie avec des un chèque de 100
millions de dollars à quoi joue-il
sachant que en Israël on entend quand
même un jugement très sévère sur lui et
oui mais vous avez raison mais je vais
reprendre votre terme en fait il ne
pilote pas le pays il ne pilote pas de
pays il il pilote sa propre survie
politique voilà et ça tout le monde le
comprend en Israël il y a beaucoup il y
a beaucoup mais on sait jamais avec lui
mais oui politiquement il est il est
mort il cherche juste la porte de sortie
et de si possible de pas aller en prison
trop vite pour dire les choses très
clairement il a des il a des procès ce
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre il va il va
y avoir des commissions d'enquête d'un
niveau incroyable vous savez que Israël
c'est un pays voilà qui qui qui qui est
criticable sur plein de points de vue
mais enfin c'est un pays où on est
capable de mettre les les anciens
premier ministres en prison hein et
Olmer oui Olmer dans Histoire de de
corruption un ancien président d'Israël
en prison également pour harcèlement
sexuel enfin voilà c'est un pays où il y
a quand même un droit encore donc il est
c'est c'est un une des clés du problème
c'est que nataniiaou devrait être parti
de lui-même normalement enfin n'importe
quel premier ministre normalement
constitué le 7 au soir il s'en va il
sécurise la suite il demande à benigans
de le remplacer et il part d'accord si
par pas c'est aussi que il y a pas il y
a pas
d'alternativeorsil cherche on parle
beaucoup de Marwan bargouti du côté
palestinien en ce moment un président
président président l'ABS par israis
palestinen Israël don on parle pourendre
un leadership palestinien du côté
israélien on le cherche le grand leader
qui devait faire la paix c'était Rabine
il a été assassiné par l'extrême droite
israélienne voilà c'est c la même qui a
pris le pouvoir aujourd'hui benigand
n'est pas un grand leader c'est pas un
leader charismatique pas du tout mais
c'est quelqu'un de rassurant c'est un
c'est un ancien militaire c'est
quelqu'un qui a la confiance des
militaires quelqu'un qui a fait la
guerre voilà ce serait une espèce de au
moins de transition qui permettrait de
calmer le jeu et de sortir du jeu
politicien de netaniaou qui est
délétaire mortifère pour les populations
civiles de Gaza évidemment pour la
société civile israélienne pour la
stabilité régionale pour tout le monde
en fait sa un petit mot à l'historien
que vous êtes rappelez-nous pourquoi
pour Benyamin netaniaou la question des
otages est si personnel en TB Jonathan
netaniaahou son frère oui en TB c'est
mais c'est une situation différente en
TB c'est un avion dans lequel il y avait
plein d'Israéliens qui a été détourné
par par des combattants palestiniens et
la décision de l'assaut a été prise tout
de suite il y a des des des forces
spéciales israéliennes c'est une
opération couronnée de succès il y a un
seul mort qui est le propre frère de
Benjamin nataniaou et qui est devenu un
héros national à ce moment-là la
différence c'est que en TB c'est une
prise d'otage allz dire classique comme
pour prendre un exemple qui va parler à
nos téléspectateurs comme l'hypercacher
ou comme munique d'une certain manière
c'estd on a des otages localisé enfermé
dans un bâtiment avec des ravisseurs
dans ces cas-là si la négociation
n'aboutit pas très vite c'est l'assaut
haut tech l'ASS fonctionneou l'ASS ne
fonctionne pas là on est complètement
dans autre chose d'abord ils sont
beaucoup plus nombreux ils ne sont pas
localisés on peut pas aller les chercher
l'assaut n'est pas une option d'accord
et la preuve c'est qu'ils en onont pas
trouvé pendant toute la toute la durée
dans le dans le Nord donc voilà il
peut-être qu'effectivement sur le plan
personnel c'est important pour lui mais
ça ne lui est aucun secours pour
analyser la situation qu'il a en face de
lui merci beaucoup pour cet éclairage on
sent la flamme de l'historien optimiste
et ça fait plaisir comment vous
expliquez d'un mot ce phénomène de 000
exempla je pense que oui oui et puis on
a une traduction dans une dizaine de
langues dont l'arabe et l'hébreu je
pense que les gens oui je pense que les
gens qui nous écoutent ont envu à la
fois de se documenter sur ce qui se
passe tout en reprenant un petit peu de
champ parce qu'ils sont un peu assommés
aussi par voilà trêve pas trêve aage et
quelque chose me dit que à Noël ça va ça
va faire un gros boom vous restez avec
moi c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos parti
PRS afranchi vous vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite Léa Falco la
chronique Mariette darrand notre
séiologue un mot de la semaine comme
chaque vendredi installez-vous on
commence par Bourbon Express l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée c'est vous Marco
Pomier qui nous l'a raconté bonsoir
myiam Ce soir je vous raconte l'histoire
d'un incident de séance alors vous allez
me dire c'est la routine à l'Assemblée
oui mais on avait rarement vu une telle
tension en commission des lois c'était
hier soir aux alentours de 19h40 en
plein examen du projet de loi
immigration l'insoumis Hugo bernalicis
débarque dans la salle réclamant une
suspension de séance regardez cette
vidéo filmée par un
[Musique]
participants
Hugo bernalicis foudrage debout tapant
du point sur la table vous l'avez vu
alors pourquoi cette réaction volcanique
et bien tout simplement à cause de deux
rendez-vous qui se télescopaient au même
moment la France insoumise présenté dans
l'émicycle une proposition de loi dans
le cadre de sa niche parlementaire les
députés insoumis en commission voulaient
donc absolument rejoindre la séance
public refus catégorique de Sacha alier
pour lui pas question de suspendre les
travaux alors qu'on était au début
discussions dans l'hémicycle ce n'était
pas encore l'heure du vote monsieur
Bernal vous arrêtez vous arrêtez de vous
comporter comme un gamin turbulent lors
de la lors de la proposition de
résolution européenne sur le droit de la
mer nous avons siégé en même temps que
la discussion générale sur la
proposition de résolution européenne ça
vous a posé aucun problème votre
indignation à géométrie variable ça
suffit vous n'avez pas raison donc vous
arrêtez votre cinéma bon ça n'a pas
suffi calmer HUG bernalicis les échanges
et les invectives ont duré une vingtaine
de minutes l'insoumis s'est même
interposé physiquement face à Christophe
naagelen députelliotte pour l'empêcher
de prendre la parole pour défendre un
amendement alors pas de violence non
plus hein mais mais face à un tel
spectacle la gauche a demandé une
suspension indignation dans les autres
groupes et puis Gérald haranin n'a pas
manqué de réagir non plus
écoutez vos menaces sont monsieur gilet
non non vous donnez un spectacle
lamentable de la démocratie lamentable
Metz en sc votre nullité est-ce que les
révolutionnaires en carton que vous êtes
peuvent se taire arrêtez de vous
comporter comme vous le faites on n'est
pas dans un cirque et on n'est pas dans
vos manifestations Hugo n'est
manifestement pas prêt pour Bovo là donc
il va falloir va falloir va falloir un
petit peu murir va falloir un petit peu
murir bon éventuellement prêt pour une
assemblée générale d'étudiants mais mais
pas pour le ministère de l'Intérieur
voilà un peu d'humour sarcastique du
ministre de l'Intérieur en revanche ça
n'a pas du tout fait rire il a elbrown
pivé elle a sanctionné durement Hugo
bernalici cet après-midi rappel à
l'ordre avec inscription au procèsverbal
ce qui le privera d'un/art de son
indemnité parlementaire pendant un mois
et le député insoumis pourrait même être
plus lourdement sanctionné à l'occasion
d'un bureau de l'Assemblée le 13
décembre prochain voilà merci beaucoup
Marco il y a des choses qui ne changent
Pasin le CHU à l'Assemblée dans
l'histoire on le connaît mais là plus
que jamais hier soir en commission des
lois Léa Falco vouliez revenir sur
l'autre COP celle dont on parle beaucoup
moins il y a la COP 28 à Dubaï bien sûr
sur le climat mais il y a aussi la COP
biodiversité et oui il y a des COP
biodiversité aussi et l'année dernière
la COP 15 biodiversité à Montréal a
accouché d'un processus qui pour une
fois commence à donner des fruits
l'Assemblée avait dans le jargon un peu
techno hein de ces arènes là déclaré
qu'il fallait un cadre international
capable d'enrayer l'effondrement du
vivant en gros une feuille de route de
réduction des impacts sur la
biodiversité des pays qui participait et
la France cette semaine en début de
semaine a fourni ce cadre-là en tout cas
pour le cadre national c'est-à-dire la
stratégie nationale biodiversité c'est
la troisè il y en avait déjà eu de 20
dernières années alors qu'est-ce que
propose la France la stratégie française
il y a 40 mesures différentes PEL Mel on
peut citer rapidement la réduction de 50
% de la pollution lumineuse la réduction
de la consommation d'espace naturel ou
encore la protection accrue de certaines
zones qui le sont déjà et alors quelles
sont les bonnes mesures dans tout ça bah
il y a des mesures qui sont un petit peu
sinon gadget au moins pas tout à fait
convainquantes sur le plan écologique
par exemple cette fameuse histoire de
planter un milliard d'arbres alors que
peut-être que ce serait plus intéressant
selon la spécificité des forêts locales
d'adapter les essences pour rendre les
espaces plus résilients et surtout
d'embaucher des gardes forestiers pour
s'en occuper mais grosso modo sur le
principe cette SNB stratégie nationale
biodiversité c'est quand même une bonne
chose c'est un vrai pas en avant en plus
par rapport à la précédente mouture
qui était beaucoup moins avancé et point
important il y a un financement d'un
milliard d'euros qui a été déclaré sur
l'année 2024 donc même si c'est pas
assez évidemment c'est déjà un vrai bon
point maintenant quand on regarde
l'intérieur de laasnb il y a quand même
deux trois choses à relever déjà sur le
fond il y a une un vrai problème qui est
que un certain nombre des mesures qui
sont prises ou qui sont mentionnées sont
en fait des choses qui existent déjà
dans d'autres stratégies ou dans
d'autres plans donc c'est juste un
rappel de l'existance sans moyens
supplément ça c'est un grand classique
hein ah oui évidemment mais ça pose des
vraies questions quand même derrière et
puis sur sur le fond toujours il y a pas
vraiment de mention du modèle agricole
et donc du de la transformation des
modèles agricoles qui quand on parle de
biodiversité est une vraie question
après évidemment sur la forme bah c'est
une stratégie donc ce n'est pas une loi
ce n'est pas contraignant ça n'a pas de
valeur juridique en propre et puis
surtout cette SNB elle fait l'examen ou
en tout cas le bilan de la précédente de
la précédente mouture qui allait de 2014
à 2020 et ce qu'elle note c'est que je
la cite les pression affectant la
biodiversité n'ont pas été réduites
significativement par la stratégie
précédente qui a eu un rôle insuffisant
bon ça mérite d'être clair et la
question maintenant c'est comment est-ce
que cette nouvelle stratégie va avoir un
réel impact va avoir une réelle mesure
sur la qualité de la biodiversité en
France parce que on le rappelle c'est
pas seulement la résilience de
l'Agriculture de l'Alimentation et de
tout ce que vous voulez sur le simple
point de vue économique le World
économicque Forum estime que plus de 50
% du PIB mondial sur plus de 44
milliards de dollars 44000 milliards de
dollar provient four par la nature
autant dire que c'est un gros sujet bon
merci beaucoup merci Léa on enchaîne un
peu rapidement vous l'avez senti
Mariette vouz revenir sur le mot ultra
c'est votre choix forcément cette
semaine avec d'ailleurs des nouvelles
manifestation à Lapp de l'ultra droite
qui ont été interdites he dans tout le
pays oui je crois qu'il faut
s'intéresser à ce petit préfixe un petit
signifiant comme ça l'air de rien mais
qui est revenu dans le débat public
alors il vient du sport récemment c'est
l'univers du sport des des supporteurs
de foot les ultras de Marseille bon
c'était un des groupes qui soutenait
peut-être soutient encore l'OM les
tiphosis Italiens les hoouigan et cetera
on voit on voit ça avec un pied dans le
monde ouvrier on voit sur le look du du
de l'ultra il est à la fois très
physique très sportif il h il doit
courir aujourd'hui on voit des
acrobaties à la fin des manifes et on
voit aussi des signifiants disons de
type prolétaire avec des blousons avec
des cases des cagoules et cetera nous
dans notre tradition évidemment nous
avons les ultras alors c'est curieux
parce que les ultra au moment de la
restauration était un groupe royaliste
attaché à l'intégrisme catholique donc
c'est quand même assez différent mais ça
fait partie de bah du du de la
composition oua c'est le courant de de
la droite légitimiste qui a bien été
décrit par Rener Raymond exactement
alors ce serait intéressant d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui qui nous aide à comprendre
un peu comment tout se fait parce que il
y a un brouillage idéologique sous le
terme ultra on peut aussi retrouver
aussi bien des gens de droite que de
gauche même si en ce moment on parle
plutôt des ultras de droite mais et sous
C cette couleur noire finalement
distingue pas très bien dans les looks
est-ce qu'on est sur des le noir de
l'anarchie ou le noir de l'intégrisme
c'est c'est pas très clair alors c'est
d'ailleurs très intéressant parce que le
monde de l'art contemporain s'intéresse
à la notion et vous savez que l'art
contemporain mélange beaucoup de codes
aujourd'hui donc il y a par exemple un
geste des de certains artistes
performeers qui vont transperser un mur
avec de la peinture ou avec leur propre
corps et ça fait c'est magnifique et
cetera c'est une sorte de exploit euh
qui qui qui réfère aussi bien au sport
qu'à la politique qu'à la beauté
visuelle ou au code instagramable on
pourrait dire donc ça veut dire qu'il y
a une forme quoi d'esthétisation de la
violence avec ce mot qu'on retrouve
partout tout façon oui ça ça doit nous
inquiéter il y a d'autres situations la
violence a souvent été le le prétexte à
une mise en en
esthétisme un romantisme de l'image si
on veut mais c'est là que je voulais
appuyer aujourd'hui pour finir Miriam ça
c'est ça qui est important qui va être
important pour nous en 2024 il faut
suivre ce petit préfixe parce que si on
se représente notre vie politique sur
l'échelle de richetre idéologique le
fait qu'on est ultra aujourd'hui qui
fasse monter d'un cran et bien
paradoxalement ce qui est en dessous
c'est-à-dire extrême extrême droite
extrême gauche ça adoucit donc il y a un
paradoxe là qui est profondément à mon
avie inquiétant une espèce d'effet
soupline de l'idéologie que nous allons
avoir à surveiller je crois parce que ça
c'est très malfaisant merci merci
beaucoup beaucoup ça vous inquiète
l'arrivée de ce mot en 2 secondes c'est
pas le mot qui inquiète c'est la chose
c'est la réalité derrière bien sûr merci
beaucoup Vincent lumir je voilà
reconseille même si je crois que vous
n'avez pas besoin de publicité ça marche
tout seul Jérusalem avec les dessins de
je cherche son prénom Christophe Gautier
c'est-à-dire aux éditions Les Arènes
merci les affranchis c'est le weekend
profitez bien à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
he